der nächste gegenstand doch vorsicht
positiv etwas vorsichtig durch
vorsichtig was geht ab jetzt bekommen
wir ein video erneut ich hoffe hat würde
ich euch jetzt gut die meisten von euch
werden sich jetzt sicherlich schon
fragen wofür benötigen wir heute dieses
klebeband das ist doch wirklich eine
sehr gute berechtigte frage wofür
brauchen wir dieses spiel dann weißt du
wir machen eine tolle zellen also wir
haben uns für heute gebe es hier wären
uns leute nämlich ein chat überlegt und
zwar gibt es ja diese videos was ist in
der box wo man das halt so erfüllen muss
das wollen wir gar nicht machen das gibt
es ja schon jurist auf die geniale idee
gekommen
lass uns das doch einfach mal so machen
dass man halt nur schütteln darf
und durch dieses schütteln erraten muss
was drin ist kannst du nicht noch diese
werbung für diese junge alles geschickt
hat ja ich habe hier die kleinste box
aus meinem zimmer geholt und wir haben
uns jeder vier gegenstände rausgesucht
die vier- oder die tun wir immer
abwechselnd rein dann wird das ganze
hier mit kohls zurücklegt und der andere
muss dafür schütteln muss dann am sound
erraten was der winter und an gewicht
und so habe ich einfach aufsteiger sinne
von sinne verlassen das würde ich sagen
das lag mir auf der zunge also ich würde
sagen will aber gar nicht lange wir noch
ein paar was jetzt schon mal 10.000
lieblingsland stickstoff der
gewinnschlag schlug schnick schnack
schnuck
sie verstecken ich habe jetzt mal gesagt
alle hier ich nehme als erstes das hier
sollte das klebeband hat einen leichten
fehler
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt jemand ans
man kann sich abreißen deswegen machen
es ist also derjenige hält das hier halt
zu ok ich hab' das war ich glaube ich
weiß ist eine schere
nein hat er versucht hat jeder drei okay
du bist mir langsam
also es ist auf jeden fall nicht schwer
also wenn man es mit gefühl macht ist
glaube ich leicht erraten sie so viele
tipps gegeben wo sollte ich das denn
wissen bald ist es nicht versucht nur
zwei okay ich rate ein feuerzeug falsch
es ist jetzt langsam dann höchstens
vielleicht ja aber unmöglich aber ist
ein guter kriegen also ist ein shooter
ging schon so also nächstes bin ich dann
so jetzt bin ich hier
ach so war ich zeige es euch das hier
hat er noch nicht
[Applaus]
sind der pflicht und der drohnen ein
aber ist schon mal nicht schlecht das
ist ja irgendwas aneinander hängen also
ich sag mal so es ist ich will jetzt
auch nicht zu viel verraten das ist ein
da hab ich mehrere von custom ehre für
lampe kabel
nein ein versuch hast du noch schütteln
aber ich sag mal so nettes accessoire
das ich mir noch einen tipp geben
[Musik]
das ist ja übel zu verwirken zusammen
guck mal das ist abgefeiert wurde horst
junge dann hast du die kaputt gemacht
doch gesagt das sind so zwei teile teilt
dann kann ich aber nichts für das hat
man kann hier leute die scheiß brille
ist heute ja das junge das waren meine
lieblings brille ja wieso hat nicht die
jetzt kaputt gemacht hast du
festgestellte liegen die schraube ist
das ist das nächste mal 100 puppen
gucken
guck mal was
[Musik]
also ist was größer ist eine flasche
wein versuchen noch mal ein ski schuh
versuche zwei überlegen war ich gibt es
ja ich habe schon sehr lange das ist
eigentlich ein richtig guter tipp wenn
du jetzt genau darauf achtet wie sich
das anhört dann weißt du weißt glaube
ich nicht wie die scheiß dinger heißen
sonst ja ich weiß nicht wie es heißt
bestimmt
der mini mini stimmt nicht der wirbel
[Musik]
das hättest du ich dachte dass wir
dieses million dinge da ist noch so ein
ding aber das habe ich nicht lange
ok so leute kommen wir zum nächsten
gegenstand jetzt nicht so schlimm
jetzt bin ich mal gesagt hier gucken uns
wie du fou ist kein schuh
ich sag mal so macht spaß damit zu
spielen
das ist sich jetzt doch was irgendwo
spielzeug der weg ist es ist schon den
nerv kann
das sind nochmal 2 1 hast ja noch
ich habe es noch nicht lange erläutert
er welche ausgelassen
für uns ist das für mich zählt jetzt nur
regenwasser nicht die welt wirklich
scheiße
ja es gibt auch das ist dass ich immer
sagen was ich wollte sogar sagen ich
habe den kopf ich habe den da unten
gesehen den anderen ja aber ich nehme
diese chance kommt dieser ich habe daran
gedacht hatte diesen tricks karton im
service kaputt gemacht ja nicht schlimm
ja weil apple wäre das jetzt nur dabei
gewesen dass wir viel zu ja ich hab dann
gedacht sagen ja ich und zwar ist das
hier mein eigener ball da steht alex wie
drauf davon habe ich noch alle zweifel
weil das ist meiner den andern hier
dadurch verlosen und zwar ist ja von den
ball de die machen so personalisierte
bälle ist ein guter service dabei das
heißt wenn ihr glück habt auf den ball
kommentiert einfach was tippt ihr wird
die wm gewinnen und dem ist aber nicht
so einfach in meinem kanal
das ist ja selbstverständlich das ist ja
ganz so selbstverständlich und ok wir
als nächstes ich weiß nicht was richtig
sieht musste dann gerade so mit
schütteln
sonnenschein sonnenschein dingen nein
dort mit raketen
es gibt zwei versuche kaugummi da ich
mal für die schützenbrüder ganz toller
gegenstand einfach alles mögliche sein
es kann auch wieder das ticket ist
anders zu spielen aber jetzt hat dieses
komische flop dingen nein ich weiß ist
nicht so sein weil ich weiß es nicht
timo werden heja aber toll das ist doch
wieder ich habe doch gesagt könnte
wieder ein sticker seien aber ist sehr
finster java kann man sowas zu erraten
das ist während bekannt wer können denn
so eine scheiße er war das hättest du
erwarten können nie im leben angekommen
du weißt doch dass ich so was du hast
auch eine sonnenbrille mit zwei aber das
war ja nicht extra dass du hast jetzt
ich hab' das ist wochen hat verleiht war
es nicht kommen wir zum nächsten
gegenstand
bis es soweit ist dass die idee
kopfhörer einfach so oder so aber nein
wenn ich also es war ungefähr also von
der form her passt es circa und es sind
insgesamt vier stücke drin vier stück
es ist ein zusammenbringen dagegen stand
also es in vier verschiedenen und die
hängen jeweils zu zwei aneinander
das war jetzt schon tipps zu viel
eingehen ja ich habe keine ahnung
keine ahnung du hast schon mal gesagt da
ist nichts nachzustehen wieder unten und
hat ein junge der das hättest du jetzt
aber erraten können habe ich dir aus dem
schrank geklaut naja ok der nächste
gegenstand
da vorsichtig
etwas vorsichtiger vorsichtig 9 880
kurzweg warum ich musste etwas anderes
überlegen guck mal ich hab gesagt wo
sich ja nun mal was anderes wollte als
sein handy
stell dir vor ich hier und meine hand
gehabt ich dachte auch kraft ist
vorsichtig
ok diesmal kein gefährlicher gegenstand
ist das gehör zerbrechlich wittmann ist
kaputt gehen
ach kommen sie zu uns neulich war dass
es so schwer man man stelle sich das
glaube ich leichter vor als es ist ihr
habt eine zeitlang sehr gerne gespielt
taschen vergleicht was denn der mini
helikopter okay leute letzter gegenstand
also das kann man jetzt ich glaube das
ist das leichter studiert es ist eine
trinkflasche
[Musik]
ist von mir ja
statt auf sein zimmer geholt und jetzt
aber auch nicht
es ist eins gemein ist ein handy es ist
ein iphone
vielleicht wird ja nicht alles kaputt
gemacht geht noch gesagt du hast da
hätte ich aufgehört ich wollte es nicht
schlimm als wenn das darin kaputt geht
ja ein paar schrammen sind jetzt hier
kann es mir eigentlich neues köpfen aber
ich brauche immer neues 18 wieder neues
ja heute verlierer muss jetzt das bis
zum ende des videos zeigen genau
vielleicht ich habe die jugendliche
fahren falls ja auf jeden fall die
daumen nach oben drauf instagram und
wenn ich noch ein passwort ein mann
steht dass das ist wirklich schwerer als
man denken ich nehme wir uns dass ich
würde dass wir nichts verraten haben
aber ich hatte meine kommentare titel
gewonnen ich weiß doch mal in die
kommentare und wie man die charity
verbessern könnte oder so was er heute
aber nicht vergessen wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich morgen also wieder hat
ein